♪♪
FOE R JEEZY  HASEEN KNOW
YSHE IT RE. N UT HISMEAL
EVEN" -- WITH HIM. FI IS  CAN'TN
R WOUT AS A
>> WEL FELN BENNDISHONEST AN
LEARNED THAT LIFS ABOU
AMBITIOUS AND I
THAT BACK THENMEINESS,ND MANDMA
CAN DEAL WITH
ANYTHING BUTD A THIEF.
>> LOT OR GRAN
THING.U THEY T ESUY IS OUT THS
HE'S WEARING A NIC WATCH.
THEY SEE THESE THINGANO , WHFOL?
WHI WROTE THE BOOKPEOPLE SEE TH.
THIS H B OF ME
GOING THROUGH ERT H AND EVEN B
ABOUT  OK A IS BECAUSE YOU WANT.
EVEN AMY.
E TO UNDERSTAND LIFEOT. NOT FAI.
TORY IS ABOUT.E D SEIT'S
CT.O TELLABOUT HOPE
GO.>>K IUR BOOK.
R SEVERAL
YEY UNMFORTABLE
FEELING.
LL THOD YOU ORREAK YOW LITTLE B
I WOULD SAY TH
THE THING THEY GOT ME ON M
LING IS THAT I
STARTED TO LEARN AND USTWHECAUSE
I THOUWAS WR ME.
YOU COME FROM POVERTY, THIS ISE
AS A BLA MANIT'S WEAK TO
FOR ME, I HAE  YOU.
HARD WAY.Y NEEDS ME
AND I DIDN'T KNOW I HAD TR.
OUGHT THESE ARE THE THINGS O TH.
T
NORMAL.
>> WHEN YOU LOSE FRIENDSA
YOUNG E,THND GOING AWAY DOIN0
'S A NOTHING G, YOU D'T
DE
AS YOU GET INTO YOUR ADULT LIFE,
YOU WONDER WREE  BUT IT'S COMINA
IF YOU AIN SEE
O FACENS
YOU ARE WAG DIRECTION.
HIAR
ERND
VEND BE IN
MY RIGHTD FOR THAND I WASN'T TH
MAALL THY T.RKG.BUT  I
BETTER STATE YHE
IN RTH
YON A NUMBERV HOP.
ARE DEEP. ST THEY
HAVE BEEN THROUGH TRYING TO HELP
OTHER PEOP
THROUGH THE SA THINGT YOU
ALSO HAVE MISONY
DRU WORRY ABOUT THIN HIP MASSESI
>> I THINK IT'S THE MESSAGBE THK
IT WAS MY UTH.
THE REALITY IS N O.
IT O CAN'T CONTROL OURVIS  SURS
OFTI THESE
HEOPING   OTHER PEOPLE.CAUSE ITF
THEM AS WE CHANGED M.
STENEDACEASON I HALES AND A ASSS
SAID.
SO HAD MOING THAT'S WHAT MY
MUSIC WAS DOING.
USIC WAS
EVNG LWAYS A MESSAGE BVE. T HADT
MO GOTO TT'S A
IS A BT
.
N  F'S SO RAW ANRE